and then you can stand up and make any
adjustments now imagine if that were
like your breasts they're doesn't
doesn't look half bad
feminism is all the rage today and the
latest affront to them is man spreading
a matter of fact it's so offensive that
it was just banned in Madrid and their
proposals to banned it across other
areas of Europe and here in the United
States man spreading man spreading man
spreading employee sitting posture that
some men see as their natural right
a guy spreads his legs yeah takes up too
much room
stick into my legs a sleazy type of guy
that sits there like this it's just
really discourteous what if we have it
all wrong when it comes to man spreading
what if all this man focused guilt is
misplaced by the feminists the activists
the lecturers and legislators once
misconstrued as a sociological symptom
of patriarchy recent medical research
reveals that the practice of man
spreading is in fact the result of
biological cofactors the reproduction
organ portion of the man Anatomy is
incredibly sensitive if the man sits
down in the improper position the size
create immense pressure on the scrotum
testicle glans penis creating immense
neurological discomfort though not as
severe so often ignored the chef's not a
fan of it either in this social
experiment we'll see what women think
using our homemade apparatus it's
prickly are you familiar with the term
manspreading yes I think so
yes man spread yeah you ever hear that
no do you man spread try not to
your man's fitting right now I got some
nerve on you sweater vest
would you consider yourself a feminist I
think everyone should be you don't man
spread what about your balls though when
you when you don't spread a little bit
just takes up a lot of room like more
than like a 45-degree angle is too much
it's not okay to make other people feel
dramatically uncomfortable sure but what
if a guy is in like I'd be a little bit
in your space I have a benefit just by
being born milk-like privilege sure
exactly now that's not to say that there
are times when I don't have that same
privilege so you've heard about walking
a mile and someone else's shoes yes what
do you care to put that to the test the
scientific test will you walk a mile in
our undergarments not even a pause for
those wondering this is a device in
question it is your run-of-the-mill
jockstrap we filled it with some soft
dog toys some Kong balls and since you
can't really recreate the discomfort of
actually squeezing an organ there are
some zip ties here just to create slight
discomfort when they close their legs
nowhere near what we feel mind you but
walk a mile in our dick I don't know if
you noticed this right now but you're
already in my space is that how you
usually sit it changed your whole stance
I get one
yeah I feel the need zoo is it
uncomfortable why actually you wouldn't
do that yeah okay sit how it's
comfortable for you find your comforts
now imagine if that were like your
breasts they're really good yeah it's a
lot more inconvenient than I would
yeah we call this maybe an example of
female privilege could you maybe a see
why a lot of young men are pretty upset
because they feel as though they're
being guilted for something they have no
control over
shut that mattress because of yeah okay
a lot of the arguments are about people
trying to regulate how they control
their bodies and this is kind of the
same way except like flipped over for
men so what did we learn in all of this
well namely that the feminists you read
about online are very different from
actual women you'll meet in real life
and it turns out that if you sit down
and talk with people you can actually
get them to see your point of view
especially if you're assisted by an
incredibly low-budget unbelievably
uncomfortable contraption that mimics
the male genitalia it seems that
everybody once they added explain to
them at least had a better understanding
and we could find some common ground
unless you're this guy get a little more
comfortable bands or maybe you need to
get bigger for us to learn more such
valuable lessons outside of the realm of
social justice warrior ISM which is of
course not constrained by the bounds of
science or scientific theory subscribe
to this channel and you will be more
educated for it